we've been told about other ways of
knowing
um
other ways of doing maths
non-race anti-racist science and all
this sort of thing
yet we do not go to any aboriginal
communities for vaccines
we go to no first peoples for cancer
treatment
we go to them for no mathematical
scientific or artistic discoveries
we do not go to them to rediscover other
languages and other cultures
partly largely because such communities
seem to have had not much interest in
other cultures unlike the western mind
they seem not to have taken a great
interest
[Music]
so the
not courteous thing
would be us saying
we've been courteous for an awfully long
time and we're going to stop because it
seems not to be doing us much good
all right i'm dave rubin and we are on
location
in my house because i think that counts
as the location i think it does yeah
there you go and i am with my friend and
multiple author you've written 800 books
if i'm not mistaken
but your new book his new book is right
here it is the war on the west
douglas murray how are you my friend
great great to be with you again 800 how
many no i think this is number seven
numbers it's a little overshooting by
number seven but
my team told me this morning that this
officially today marks your ninth
appearance on the rubin report ninth yes
and there is some debate as to whether
you have now tied gad sad for number two
at nine where there's a question there's
one little question related to if he's
actually eight or nine depending on
which way you want to count jordan
peterson is 10 but you are you are
solidly second so and i was your what
second
guest ever you were yeah you were like
my second or third guest back in 2015.
we're still doing it
however my friend there is a war on the
west yeah this country is burning see
how i did that with my book too very
very clever um
so let's sort of start with that you
know for all the years that we've been
talking about all of this stuff that now
is known as wokism which you write about
obviously but all of the culture wars
and all of the things that are happening
should we have been yelling louder say
seven years ago when we all started
talking about this this loose group of
people that were kind of signaling did
we miss something and maybe should have
been screaming louder or
was it going to happen no matter what i
think it was going to happen no matter
what i i learned from the years i was
writing about islamism that
you can spend 23 hours a day
dealing with a subject but if you're
dealing with fanatics they're spending
24 hours a day doing it you just can't
you can't win in a way against fanatics
in the short term
um and what we've realized in recent
years is that the let's say the woke uh
bandwagon these people are
radicals they're extremists they're
fanatics they have an extraordinary
set of claims and they have just managed
to push them bulldoze them right into
the
center of all of our lives and as they
as that movement has sort of crept
closer and closer to people people
realize that there were no effective
barricades
i mean i say in the book that you know
there was a sort of for instance as a
conservative idea which was mistaken
which many people including myself i had
in recent years which was for instance
that things like the critical race
theory the intersectionality all of this
crap
that it would stop at the borders of the
stem subjects it would say it would
never it would never take over
engineering it would never get into
medicine
you know that would be wrong you mean it
would never tell us that two plus two
equals five exactly you know there's an
assumption that you know okay they'll do
this with with the liberal arts they'll
do this with political science and stuff
but they won't do it with engineering
and the joke because you know it was
always well at some point the bridges
have to stay up
and then
i said no it turns out we'll see it
turns out they don't yeah
if the bridges come down now it'll be
because we live in a cis heteronormative
patriarchal racist society which has
institutional racism which is why the
bridge fell down
uh
so it's it's just flooded across
everywhere and um and there's always
that question of whether you could have
done more or shouted more or whatever
but
um
i think that a lot of people didn't
realize the scope of what was coming at
us
you have the line that i've quoted
probably 50 times on twitter and 50
times on my show and probably on other
people's shows that i think perfectly
encapsulates what's going on here which
is that one day you said this to me
probably five years ago one day the
barbarians will be at the gate and will
be debating what gender pronouns to call
them yeah does that really sum up almost
exactly where we are and that really
sort of gets to the title book that we
really are at a societal war right now
and instead of really focusing on what's
going on we are debating trans swimmers
yeah and
women with penises and the rest of this
yes yeah i know i mean it is it is
deranging and after i wrote about
what i regard as being this sort of
crowd arrangement in my previous book in
the madness of crowds uh i could see it
already that this was this was happening
it was getting worse and worse people
were being in it was people were being
demanded to say things they knew not to
be true
um and and now it's got to a stage
beyond that i always thought that that
thing with that i described in the
madness of crowds was was a sort of step
towards something
that you know that the
say the
guy with a penis is a girl or
you know you're a bigot that
and i think i may even have said it to
you that it was it was almost like it
was preparing us for something because i
always maintained at the time if you if
you assault
uh the the basic things we know to be
true like the fact that there are boys
and girls and women that you're not
assigned to sex at birth as if it's a
sort of lottery system which if you've
got a particularly bigoted delivery
nurse you know she's just kind of you
know it's not that's not how it works
there are
there are boys and girls and and but but
that if you persuade people that that's
not true
you can do an awful lot afterwards
because
you've made people doubt things the the
things they were absolutely certain
about you know the the cry now it's like
well you know how do you know i mean
you're a biologist and as a a fine
british feminist said to somebody the
other day uh said well i'm not a vet
either but i know what a dog is um so
yeah exactly
but but but a lot of people have been
browbeaten and karen and and i think
that
what i'm trying to describe here is what
i think is the next stage of this
which is a war on the fundamentals of
everything in our society
a war on our history a war on our past
to warn our foundations
warn our culture
and a war on the people in the culture
what i described as a war on white
people
which is a phrase that a lot of people
will sort of jump at but
there's there's no other way to describe
it now lots of different bigotries exist
in the world but the only one that's
completely tolerated and indeed
encouraged in 21st century america is
hatred of and diminishment of people for
being white we wouldn't tolerate it with
any other skin color we wouldn't
tolerate it if people said that black
people should be treated differently
because of their skin color
only white people is this now
permissible with and that's because
white people are the inheritors of the
west they're portrayed as the people of
the west who must therefore pay for the
sins of the west you know it's funny i
was watching in the last couple weeks a
movie there will be blood did you happen
to see it with daniel day-lewis about
about the gold rush well not the golden
oil rush and going west in the 1800s
into the 1900s and it's you know it's a
lot of white people doing horrible jobs
horrible jobs in the coal mines and
digging and things collapsing on them
and people dying and fires and all of
these things
and it was making me think boy we we
talk about the history of this country
as if these white people first off as if
they built all of this stuff in honor of
whiteness which is which is completely
insane completely insane and not true
even even in an iota of a percent but
also that these people who happen to be
white who built stuff
often was very dangerous and lots of men
were dying in the process well i mean i
give i give a number of examples of this
there are two there are two original
sins of the west that are seen now
slavery and empire
but both are portrayed as if nobody else
in the world did them yeah uh which is
nonsense there were no slaves before
america right i mean you know
almost if i reckon that not one in a
million americans knows the following
fact that
um 11 to 12 million slaves were probably
brought across the atlantic from africa
during the slave trade the transatlantic
slave trade
um about 18 million africans were
similarly sold by their neighbors and
others uh in the slave trade that went
east
so why do we not know about the 18
million slaves that went east from
africa
because there's no remnant of them
because the arabs castrated all the men
does as i say does one in a million
americans know that context this that
that
slavery happened everybody was involved
in it it was a horrible thing then it's
a horrible thing now and it's still
going on now
um i've met slaves myself people who've
been born into slavery in africa
um and
i don't think anyone knows this and so
everyone's got the context all out of
sorts and the other one of course is is
empire and again these things are these
things are talked about as if no no
other
nobody else did this
you know
countries across the world tried to form
or did form empires if you're going to
get the sense of the british empire into
context you've got to understand that if
you want to get the history of the
transatlantic slave trade into context
you've got to understand what else was
going on and as you say that crucial
thing that but it's not like everybody
in the past in the west was like living
in clover you know
during the the latter stages of the um
of the slave trade the transatlantic
slave trade the average life of a man
working in one of the mills in one of
the towns in the north of england was
about 37. wow they lived into their late
30s
people on slave plantations lived longer
now i'm not saying that slave
plantations were good or anything like
it of course not i'm just saying like
can you honestly look at this and think
that those
those white if we must say that men in
the northern english mill towns were
free did they actually have any
any or much agency in their lives
did they have control of their lives
were they were they privileged no
not at all
and it's a grotesque thing of our time
that we've decided that we've got to
pretend that these people were wildly
privileged as well as bigoted privileged
bigoted and again that they did it in
the name of whiteness or of power when
it was they were literally just trying
to survive and often had to leave
families to take the worst kind of jobs
so i kind of want to go through the the
chapters of the book because one thing
that you do that i just think is so
great in all your books you do very few
chapters which i always think is just
such a clean way of writing so you
really only have four chapters in this
book and then you have some some sub
chapters within that but before we get
to that um since we are at this place
where the war seems to be here
are you surprised at all that maybe not
the punditry class that's been warning
about this but just that our
institutions didn't have better defenses
like even now even now watching the the
colleges crumble like there's still no
defense you know i remember a few years
ago the university of chicago put out a
defense of free speech and everyone said
this is it this will be the one that
will defend and i remember saying no
this isn't gonna be it's you know it'll
be okay there for a little bit maybe or
the harpers letter where people sign
things inevitable this is the one yeah
yeah and yet it has just marched and
marched until march are you surprised
this institutions
or our political leaders or something
didn't have something in the tool
yeah i think there's a tendency um we
all have that in whatever is the thing
we know about we think that it's going
to go it may go wrong there but it won't
go wrong in that discipline so i i had
this i sort of thought well
they said surely the mathematicians
aren't going to do this other ways of
knowing yeah
but here we are here we are we've got
equitable maths being taught in the us
uh
um i thought i thought we're surely not
going to get in the medical field but
but some of the race huxters uh that i
write about in this book
uh they flooded through the medical
field i was speaking dramatic offending
the medical profession the other day and
you know i was saying i just can't
believe it's like i thought medical
journals like there was no way they
would start to get into stuff about
problematizing whiteness
yeah here we are so i guess i guess my
question really then is more about the
political institutions that
it's not like we have well i was about
to say it's not like we have laws that
punish people based on the cognitive
skin but we kind of do and during covid
we were prioritizing in certain places
yes covid vaccines based on the color of
skin and all that yes and other medical
procedures and other right exactly we
genuinely were so
should politic did something we screw up
something politically there too i mean
or just our politicians are usually just
weak except for the guy who happens to
be running this state well
you know i think that
politicians see a cost-benefit analysis
and things
it's it turns out one of the
disappointments of my life has been the
i made the presumption of people in
politics are interested in truth yeah
that's not the case you're not 22
anymore are you douglas
they're interested in achieving and
retaining power and there are some good
people in politics i'm not saying that
all of them are guilty of this
but
you get this cost-benefit analysis so
is there a benefit to
saying
something that everyone knows to be true
if
the cost of it is a small but very
dedicated number of people who are
determined to destroy you
um
generally speaking that chases people
away
you know and by the way that's the
history of fanaticism across the
eras uh small but very dedicated groups
of fanatics can do an outsized amount of
damage
uh by just running straight at things
right the original social media mob i
suppose yeah and and i think politicians
among others are highly susceptible to
that they they dip a toe in the water
and they just
you know have i had no idea it was as
bad as that and they don't tread on it
again newspaper editors and others are
similar
a lot of big media companies they don't
want to touch that
that that subject's electric
don't do that so yeah i mean i'm
disappointed but i'm not surprised
all right so let's uh let's start at the
beginning
chapter one is about race and we've
already touched on some of the race
stuff
i guess when i think about it
and when i was reading it it's um we
almost solved the race thing in america
we were pretty damn close you alluded to
that in the book we really were pretty
damn close and now it does seem worse
not in my day-to-day life
but at the media level the societal
level does seem worse what a what a sad
statement it's um it's partly i believe
a
misapprehension caused by a
misrepresentation of the society
so
uh obviously i may have to get straight
into it in the race chapter the death of
george floyd in the summer of george
floyd riots
um
[Music]
the if you look at the i mean we were
all it's always worth reminding
ourselves
in most countries at that point we were
made to seclude ourselves
in the months before that happened
people were literally isolated and told
by government to isolate and one of the
things that did to us i believe is that
it took away our societal antenna
you know um if we meet people if we meet
strangers friends and everything we sit
around a dinner table or stand a bar um
you try things out and you row about
things and you discuss things and you
josh about things and
and much more if you remove all of that
um
and then something terrible happens
and a group of very dedicated people say
that shows x is the case
then
you know people start to think maybe
that is maybe that is the case now i was
in britain when
george floyd
was killed but you know um
i had a moment i've known this i've
known america all my life
and i i just like double take moment
like you know
i don't think you can just kill
black people in america i'm fairly sure
you can't i know you can't
uh but here were these protests saying
we've got to stop the fact that black
people walking the streets of america
can at any point be killed by a cop
and that's that's not true
um but there was a moment of doubt uh
which is one of the reasons why police
forces in among other things countries
like my own country of birth and britain
really didn't know what to do at the
beginning of the protests and some
policemen were persuaded to take the
knee to protesters because they panicked
they thought maybe this representation
that we're being shown is true if you
look at the
opinion data that we have on
how many black people americans believe
are killed every year unarmed by armed
american police officers
the figures are out by several orders of
magnitude
um i've got the percentages in that
among among people who describe
themselves as very liberal
a significant proportion of them think
that more than 10 000 black men
are killed every year by american police
when those men are unarmed it's
something the real number i don't know
somewhere around 10. yeah it's about a
dozen yeah which is actually less than
the number of policemen killed by armed
black men so there's another debate
there yeah but yes i mean it's so it's
off by several orders of magnitude
people describe themselves as liberal
uh think that it's somewhere between one
thousand and ten thousand so you're
dealing with a completely grotesque
distorted picture of the present
that people in america and then around
the world have been persuaded to fall
for
and that has consequences
um
because if you're told that this is the
case and that you live in a society this
race then you bring up white people to
believe that they are somehow
contaminated from birth
you bring up young black kids to believe
that they are able to be hunted down and
killed in america by the state
you massively exacerbate all racial
differences
but what this has fallen into has been
this not just what i described as war on
white people but this
this
set of massive overreach claims about
what is underneath this you know well
we've always been like this you know and
so we have the starting of the rewriting
of our history in the name of racial
justice and social justice in america
you have the 1619 project no small thing
it's the new york times that rolls that
out
led by non-historian non-specialists who
make totally
verifiably false claims about the
foundations of this country
but you see the same thing in the uk in
canada
a lot of people will have missed it but
around the same time in the last couple
years there's been this stampede in
canada when there was some graves that
were found
near a church school
and then it was claimed that this these
were mass graves of chilled indigenous
children killed by the catholic church
in massive numbers
and churches were burnt down across
canada including first nations churches
not one body has been found
not one excavation has occurred
they didn't even use ultrasound
so we we have been
embedding
totally false
claims about our collective pasts
in the names of trying to refine the
present
what do you make of the way it spreads
that that falsehood and how it spreads
so you go into the numbers about what's
going on with policing in america but
there were blm riots in london as you
mentioned that that the the way it now
spreads through the internet to then
land on the shores overseas for a
problem that nobody if you would have
asked the average person i suspect if
you ask the average black person in
london four years ago do you have a real
problem with policing here i'm going to
guess that the average person would have
said no maybe somebody had some marginal
thing but what do you make of that that
that transfer oh yeah i mean there was a
head of um
blm movement in oxford
called sasha johnson i'll be careful
what i say about her because i believe
she's still in hospital
sasha johnson wrote a tweet as i had
read led some very unpleasant protests
said horrible things about white people
said on social media she wanted to make
white people her slaves that that was
the plan she said you didn't want
equality she wanted revenge
um
by the way she's nice when they're
honest about it she was completely
honest about it i say i'm being careful
about because she's a mother and she uh
was at a house party in london uh last
year and she was shot in the head
and immediately some politicians
including the black former shadowhold
secretary said
it's appalling this poor young woman has
been gunned down for her beliefs she was
gunned down by a gang of black
young men
uh who
were shooting at a house party she was
at
so again we have these kind of just
totally false narratives you import the
blm thing to oxford in england
and then you have this horrible radical
and then something terrible happens then
all of it all of it is spun through the
thing of
white racism
let's do a little sidebar for a moment
because just as you spun that story
together and all the lies and everything
else um over the last couple years are
you
[Music]
to me if someone managed to stay roughly
sane
like they're good in my book that that's
been my like
basic temperature guide on this thing
you didn't have to get everything right
none of us did but if you sort of say
roughly sane
do you sympathize with the people that
really lost it over the last couple
years because of exactly what you just
explained right there there is such a
cacophony of nonsense being spun at all
of us all the time it's it's extremely
difficult and people don't have the time
to siphon through all yeah
i do understand um
and i i have to as it were check my
privilege in a certain way
my privilege is that i'm a writer uh i
get to say what i think
um all the time um
but that's not just the privilege it's
also you do put your neck out there i
mean it's not you know it's a privilege
to a degree but you say yeah
but i mean
but i say it because
i think that that therefore sort of my
own attitude is a bit different to some
other people because i think what is
worse for people is when they see
lies
and they just have no outlet for it yeah
they just i think there is enormous
frustration brewing everywhere you know
we've been through a
couple of really difficult years so i do
have sympathy with it
um my sympathy for that is not endless
you know i don't have sympathy for the
people who've
who now believe that absolutely
everything is a conspiracy you know and
and believe that they've seen through
everything yeah i i've not got much
sympathy with that because
i mean you
it's not just that you
it's not you have to you should find
things to trust in
you you can't be completely cynical you
should find things that you know to be
true and hold on to them right if you're
the one guy who knows what's going on
you probably have an issue i i i worry
there's a lot of that there's a lot of
um
autodidacticism
really like um you know we inevitably we
educate ourselves in our ear a lot but i
am
i'm suspicious of the people who go from
being you know experts on afghanistan to
experts on uh vaccines to experts on
ukraine to experts
everyone's an expert in ukraine right
now
these people who couldn't tie their
shoes together yeah and suddenly
everyone shows everything about this
nation that i don't know and it's like
hold my you know hold my shoes up i've
got to go back to analyzing afghanistan
next week if anything kicks off there
i i'm i i i think in a way this is
because politics has become a kind of
hobby it's more than a hobby uh a hobby
and then something more for a lot of
people it's carrying an awful lot of
weight yeah so
we go from like the
the way it travels and it jumps across
ponds and then odd things are happening
in england but what about the way it
also shifts so we had two years of
everything was about race but right now
as we sit here everything's about gender
and we'll talk more about that in a
second but
that sort of thing that it seems to be
guided in a way that doesn't seem
totally coincidental to me that the way
it actually shifts like we're not doing
race that much in america right this
moment it really does seem to be more
about gender race will come back and
then gender will come back and then
climate will come yeah and everything
else
by the way i mean that sort of climate
is another one i mean the um you know i
listed this recently in a piece you know
before the
the ukraine crisis we had the covid
crisis and i mean literally dr fauci
disappeared the moment that the russian
tanks were all into it was incredible
they couldn't find him um
and then before that we had the what did
we have for the corona crisis well we
had the racist crisis we had the trump
crisis we had the brexit crisis oh we
had the climate crisis
i like
everything cannot be a crisis everything
cannot be i mean you you can't live at
that level of
hectoring
and uh
of all of those one of the ones i have
the the least time for is is is the
other people who shout about the climate
crisis there are things that are
important to address but when they
presented as
as they did at the recent summit in
glasgow one minute left to save the
planet i think you're you're you're
doing something pretty wicked now
because you're
you're making assertions and whipping
people up into fervors that are not able
to be answered i mean aoc told us we got
12 years left that was about three years
ago we're running out of time man you
know prince charles said 12 years 20
years ago
so we're gonna be okay is that what
you're telling me but that is one it's
that in some ways do you feel like
that's the hardest one to talk about i
mean look you you spent years talking
about islamism and jihad that was
obviously very hard to talk about um but
we've sort of shifted off that now
that's sort of shifted we can talk about
race we can talk about gender but
there's something about the climate one
where it's like you feel like your whole
career could just go like that if you
talk about it uh could do i mean it's
not something i do very much on but i i
i just note that the that it seems to be
one of the fallback things if other
crises are not high and hot enough at
the moment we fall back onto the climate
crisis and it's again i'm not saying
that there aren't things to address but
just the the the way in which this is
sold to the public seems to be highly um
deranging i mean you're telling
you're telling kids that that they might
not make adulthood and that's
that's a terrible thing to to do
uh and you would only do it if you were
100 certain that was the case
and they're not
well they would tell you they are but
they're really if they were they would
actually be doing something else
exactly exactly they'd be like living as
people do when they think the plane's
about to crash let's uh let's shift to
china a little bit because it seems like
everything in the world is sort of being
driven by china um and yet i don't sense
that we have as many china experts at
the moment as we have ukraine experts
will they shift so they'll be shifting
do you sense they're making the move
absolutely
where what's the basic way we should
frame a china conversation well i'm as
you know i do an interview on this
because i say um
you know what's the rest of the world
doing whilst we're doing this to
ourselves
because if you go to beijing and you
look back at us i i often find that my
books come from
looking back
my society from another place and
somebody said to me recently well how do
you define the west and i was like well
one thing is you know what it is when
you're not in it
like when you're in beijing you know
you're not in the west if you're in
tokyo you know you're not in the west
um and
what one of the things i say is like if
you look at what we're doing from places
like china or moscow
it it does look very strange and you
would get an odd picture of us
so among other things i said well what
are the chinese doing whilst we're
obsessing about social justice
what are the russians doing whilst we're
obsessing about these things
um
and the china thing in particular is
just fascinating because
there's there's no scenario in which
russia
would overtake america in global
leadership terms
it is perfectly possible within our
lifetimes we could see china become the
dominant economy in the world in fact
elon musk and others have shown you
don't
china only has to sort of grow at the
current rate to eventually get there and
um
and and i think this is
one of the things we should just be
thinking about is
some of the context we have to have in
our minds is um you know let's say
even if we in america
we in britain we in the west
managed to make every single field of
expertise exactly uh you know dominated
in america by well represented in
america by 13
uh black people you know 50 percent or
just over 50 of women
naught point whatever percent of trans
people even if we did all of that
does america beat china
now
even if we did all of those lofty that
would strike me as being a really
important question to sort out
and i can't find people in america
enough people willing to think about it
but that would be the underlying thing
is whilst we were doing all of these
strange things to our past and our
present
the only global competitor
which
has no problem with racism
is currently operating concentration
camps yeah yeah
uh i
cite some i mean just terrifically awful
racist things that
modern china and the founders of modern
china have said and done
and again i don't think one in a million
americans knows this
um i don't think one million british
people knows it
and i just this is this is the context
we need to operate in
do we have any of the defenses to to
stop
the encroachment of china or stop that
they will be the superpower and you know
even just in in the last couple days uh
joe biden said there's new world order
coming and something to the effect of
maybe we'll be in charge of it
i i i've said for many years you know if
you
if you didn't like the era of so-called
american hegemony you're gonna love the
chinese era
i have a human rights complaint you'll
tell the ccp yeah they'll love that how
interesting yeah how interesting they
have special rooms for people like us
please step this way
you know i mean it's
and it's it's really it feels horribly
late empire
what we're doing
so how do we
reverse course on this or let's say
there was if you were advising biden or
there was a new administration i know
it's not just a political answer i know
that but if you were guiding some sort
of
philosophy that was going to push back
on some of this
one thing is you've got to stop elite
capture which has definitely happened in
all of our countries i list some of the
examples of it really worrying my
profile examples in britain america
australia new zealand
canada
where
people in our political elites have been
bought up by china
and
maybe
in the future we will treat those people
as we are currently treating russian
oligarchs
finally who looted their country and
then moved to the west and
with spent their ill-gotten gains maybe
there will come a time when we actually
treat the people who
who helped china
arrive at this point from the west
with that kind of
retribution
but that would be a start
it would also be a start to address how
business is going to address this
because we know constantly businesses
that have been born in countries like
america
and have free market principles
completely adapt those principles in
order to dominate in the chinese market
should americans and others in the west
have an attitude towards this in the
products we buy in the products we
engage with i think so
well it's funny now you hear biden
saying oh we should buy more american or
we should make more american things here
it sort of sounds like something that
that orange guy was kind of sweating for
a while it was the sort of thing which
only a few years back you would have
definitely been accused of jingoism yeah
of course of course
i mean um
uh
all of us have been from the corona here
as well have had this sort of supply
chain issue suddenly come back
turns out energy independence is quite
useful
quite useful to be able to not rely on
china for all sorts of things from
medical products
all the way through to energy same with
russia you know that the the two covid
tests remember buy it and send two cova
tests to every american during the state
of the union yeah you know that they're
made in china made i have two of them i
know i i
it seems to be some unbelievably
dark
grand joke
it's like if a fiction writer was
writing it you'd be like it's too on
point no come on yeah you say
it's a novel but don't yeah don't
stretch our credulity
is there anything else we can do i guess
no a little more or is it really also
that it's just like when you when the
average person maybe is thinking about
china's encroaching on the west and the
and our hegemony and all of it's going
to collapse and you'll realize how good
you had it but it's do it it's like that
isn't as emotionally abrasive as just
like oh let's tear down a statue or
america's races something like that it's
so much to think about truly that this
country all the world away could really
be trying to upend the world that we
just totally take for granted
i think
the most important thing is that we get
ourselves into context i mean
historically we'll come on to that but i
mean historically but also in the
present i mean
again if people in america leave america
and go to certain places in the world
like china like the far east middle east
you know you'll see that
questions you tear yourselves up over
here
for right or wrong
do not bother or detain these societies
and uh
that should be sally tray
yeah you go into uh reparations yeah
in a portion of this that's uh you
described yourself as privileged because
you're an author but you know there will
be a cost for talking about reparations
my friend
well i do reparations after uh the
history chapter yeah where i describe
how yeah we've been sort of more on the
war on history the war in our history in
the west is just it just
has to stop it has to be put into proper
context i'm all for the debate by the
way i mean there's obviously a sort of
a debate on empire going on again a new
debate on slavery but all of it is as if
we haven't had these debates before as
if we've never thought about them before
and and so yes one of the questions is
now coming up again is reparations
um
britain by the way paid significant
reparations when the slave trade ended
in fact there's evidence i
analyzed and explained in the book
uh that britain actually paid more to
abolish the slave trade than it ever
gained through the slave trade
but of course because britain after we
abolished the slave trade
um also policed the abolition of the
slave trade across the high seas in the
19th century thousands of british
sailors lost their lives in those
operations stopping the brazilians for
instance who continued to slave their
slave trade into the 1880s
um stopping the brazilians and others
from trafficking people across the globe
but also britain paid the money
in in effectively reparations those who
lost money
uh they
um all all british people paid a cost
throughout the 19th century in an
upsurge of pricing of goods
because if you got rid of
buying goods from places that were
producing them from slavery
then you then of course you were paying
more so there's a lot of evidence that
britain were already paid down
it's
it's gained from the slave trade well
again not one in a million people knows
that yeah and so now when people say you
need to pay reparations for what you did
in the 18th century i think well that's
interesting same thing in this country
in the united states people talk as if
as if this country didn't fight a damn
civil war over the issue you know
um
and
i think i think i a number of times in
the book i use
um a couple of fantastic quotes of
nietzsche from on the genealogy of
morals and
one of his analogies which i lift is
he talks of people who who pick at long
closed wounds and pick off the scabs and
then scream about how much they've been
hurt
this is horribly pertinent i think
that's what we're dealing with
um we're dealing with people today who
are demanding money
for things they didn't suffer and
demanding money from people who did no
wrong
and it's got so much worse in this
latest iteration previous attempts or
claims for operations were different but
by the time you get into the current
decade and uh tana hazy coates
basically starts off this latest round
uh with peace in the atlantic but but by
the time the last democrat primaries all
the democrats were talking about
reparations seriously talking about how
to do representations one of the first
things that joe biden did when he got
into office was to was to launch an an
investigation into whether you know
whether and how this country could get
into this question even though barack
obama virtually never talked about it
just four years before right and was
black and
because it was not called assault a
sellout because of it because this a new
generation has been persuaded to open a
wound that they didn't suffer from and
scream about how much they've suffered
and um
you know there's actually this is why i
do the sub chapter on reparations is
that there's a deep moral question
within this which is at this stage it's
people who look like people to whom
wrong things were done in the past
demanding money from people who look
like people who could have done the
wrong things
um
if you want to
get further into it you have to say
you have to basically do a genetic
database of the american population
what do you do but i mean this is one of
the many moral problems is i don't
believe that anyone living has the right
to
be forgiven
and no one living has the right to
forgive they don't have the right i
explain why in in the book that simply
moral time you do not have the right to
apologize for something you did not do
and nobody else has a right to accept an
apology if the wrong was not done to
them
so we're in this
set of demands that are being made
which i'm afraid must be dismissed
um
carefully um sensitively at times and
insensitively at others
but
it's it's it's not going to work and
this idea has to be put to bed because
we are now dealing with historic
retribution not just reparations but
historic retribution
do you think that it's also designed to
intentionally inflame racial tension oh
yeah cool so if you said to a second
generation
mexican immigrant legal mexican
immigrant in the united states who
busted their butt came here now you know
they're a parent now and now they have
young kids and they had nothing to do
with slavery came here don't have that
much but are working hard for the
american dream or if you took my family
that i'm fourth generation american but
you know holocaust survivors on both
sides of my family all came here with
nothing that had nothing to do with
slavery that you would and then suddenly
you were saying to people but you have
to give money to this thing even though
we don't know whose ancestors act like
really are we gonna really be able to
track this correctly that you're gonna
end up causing people to be racist of
course of course you would of course you
would and it's dire every way you look
at it i mean here's another one what do
you do with the black people descended
from black people who sold their
brothers and sisters
do they pay out
i mean voltaire said this centuries ago
voltaire said the only thing even worse
than what the europeans were doing in
selling
black africans and trading them across
the atlantic were the africans who sold
their brothers
are we going to go to africa and find
the people who descended from the people
who did that
i mean some of the few memoirs of slaves
we have like equiano describe how their
neighbors in a neighboring village in
africa just came and stole them in the
night
is there any reparation for that are we
going to give reparations to the
millions of black people who probably
don't want it or the
immigrants from senegal who have thrived
or several other countries caribbean
countries who come here and thrive it's
it's so obviously not possible
that it's purely designed to open a
wound and to claim and to claim
superiority for for yourself
do you think it's also intentionally
counter to the way humans operate
meaning that let's say let's say we had
this grand program of reparations and
let's say all the experts got together
and tanissi coates and all of the
everyone on msnbc got their panel of
experts and all the people who aren't
willing to send who aren't willing to
show their voter id at the booth are
willing to hand over their dna
that's another good one right because
you don't have to show your id to vote
but somehow you're going to have to show
some sort of id for related to this but
okay fine but let's say we get the great
panel of all time they get every
socialist and communist on there and
race expert on there and they come up
with the number they come up with a
number that each black person in america
should get and let's just come let's
come up with an insane 250 000
per person right it's insane we're gonna
we're gonna figure out how to fund it i
know we have no money but let's say they
do the exact perfect thing that they
purport to want to do
do you think they also don't
fundamentally understand just human
nature which is that the progressives of
20 years from now will say look what our
the answer the progressives before us
did they sold us out yeah
250 grand and it won't solve anything
right and a generation on uh um there
will be new people saying that wasn't
enough
uh there's a very funny skit you've
probably seen dave chappelle do and what
would happen if yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
exactly which which are brands to get
shares in before that money was dulled
out um
it's a non-starter but it's designed to
be divisive
and
here's one of the problems that comes
from that which is that
it's so demeaning of our history in the
west it's so to me racism and
colonialism and slavery were part of the
story of the west as they have been the
part of the story of all societies
throughout human history and in many
societies today but they are not the
history of the west they are part of the
history
they are not the history of the west
and that has been totally
misrepresented in our day
as if these
sins
were the only thing that defined us
whereas actually what defined the west
was that these were things we recognized
to be sins
modern china doesn't recognize that
many other nations and countries and
societies around the world don't
recognize that
speaking of the history let's shift to
religion
this is one as you know i've definitely
come around on on the belief side at
least
very different than where i was say five
or six years ago
i think you need something behind just
the liberalism that we love to keep this
this ship going
talk to me a little bit about religion
would you douglas murray
well
um
i explained that
you basically can't you can't take down
the west unless you take down the
religious
element of it
specifically the judeo-christian
tradition
what's worrying at the moment is that
there is a simultaneous assault on the
two traditions of the west both the
philosophical tradition including the
secular tradition
and the religious tradition so
the western churches they go into a
remorseless detail even the catholic
church
judaism
uh what's that they've gone woke they've
they've decided the point of judaism or
the catholicism is social justice and
say as much
church of england episcopalians all
these people have decided that they're
going to do they go basically they're
going to give up god and they're going
to go for woke
and
that
that's not very survivable actually i
think because it just turns
the things that are meant to be the most
profound sources of meaning on your
society into just another banal
repetition of the banal
things that you get everywhere from an
art gallery to
you know cable news to everywhere else
it's just
you also get it at church or a synagogue
you know
and um so that and that's devastating
one way but
what makes it even more devastating is
that this is happening simultaneously
with an attack on the
secular philosophical traditions of the
west uh
the tradition of athens the tradition of
the enlightenment i mean in the last few
years every philosopher of the
enlightenment everyone
has been brought down
by this crowd of
anti-westerners anti-westerners
uh
they've done for voltaire who's actually
his statues disappeared in paris
they've come for david hume for john
stewart mel
for everyone
and again
that's that's because as with the
history thing that's what you have to do
if you want to destroy the west
in the same way that if you want to take
down america you have to take down the
roots of america you have to take down
its heroes you have to take down lincoln
you've got to take down jefferson you've
got to take down the gods of the
republic if in britain you've got to
take down winston churchill that's where
they go for him so bad
it's
in the same way if you want to destroy
the tradition of reason in the west you
go for the figures who gave us the
tradition of reason and everybody from
aristotle who the washington post a
couple years ago described as the
grandfather of scientific racism who
among other things stood accused of
being named by charles murray as his
favorite philosopher so yeah
and this particular writer in the
washington post was just
disturbed to find aristotle writing 2
300 years ago did not agree with
everything the washington post says in
2020 as a shocking discovery this
unbelievable realization what are you
going to do with these idiots aristotle
god
um what did he know
um and it's the same with the
philosophers and the enlightenment i
mean you could say that one of the
reasons why the philosophy of the
enlightenment have been so attacked in
recent years is because they were living
in the time of the two original sins
slavery and empire
and that they they stand accused now of
not having spent enough time thinking
about the same things that ibm ex candy
pretends to think about
or robin d'angelo well you know david
hume was trying to
work out how we got ourselves out of a
period of of
basically superstition
uh
writers like voltaire were trying to
separate out the church and the state
these are quite important tasks and
important roles should they have
dedicated themselves to other things
that we now call social justice possibly
but
they were busy with other things
you know they were busy with other
things
and uh and again there's just this
unbelievable presumption about this and
i i say i mean i'm very keen to
play the game back at them like
david hume is his attack now because of
one footnote in one of his essays which
is
known by all hume scholars and his is
racist
uh racist statement um
he's attacked for this one footnote
candy and others assault him for it i
think that's probably the only passage
of hume that candy's ever read
uh but uh
you know okay let's do this with with
other people what why um
who who who
who might fall if you did this if you
said something racist once trick who
else might fall here's one karl marx
i go through in considerable detail
karl marx's letters and his essays are
filled with racism
packed with it he uses the n-word all
over the place usually hyphenated with
jew
not used in a very flattering light
itself either
i mean marx was a horribly racist
anti-semitic uh um
a really very very bigoted figure who by
our own modern standards should not
be regarded as as survivable
nobody's done the task on him
a new statue went up to engels only a
couple years ago new statute of marks
went up yeah just uh just a couple years
ago um
so why is it only happen to these people
i think here in questions like that you
see the sources of what i'm what i'm
what i'm
trying to get at here which is that the
war on the west
is a war on all of the things we
treasure
designed to leave behind only people who
very very militant political activists
want to leave
standing
as the only people with an explanation
for our society
so this is sort of the same question
that i asked you
at the beginning in terms of
why didn't our institutions have enough
to stand up our secular institutions but
are you surprised that the religious
institutions whether you fully believe
in them or not that they didn't have
better defenses you would think that
these things that have really lasted for
thousands of years and have made
mistakes along the way and wars have
been fought and we can do that all thing
but that they that every you're not
exaggerating when you talk about what's
happening in the churches and the
temples of america right now i mean
they've traded in most of what we
thought their beliefs were and it's very
it's very strange because i mean
i agree with the
historian of christianity sort of
ancient world um tom holland who who
said in the past you know that actually
christianity for instance it should do
the weird stuff like what makes
christianity extraordinary are
the claims it makes about the world
um
if
the weird stuff as tom holland calls it
you know include you know the virgin
birth
the crucifixion the resurrection
but this is this is christianity
take them away and you haven't got
christianity
insert in its place
the same as i say but now
things that you get everywhere else in
the age and you don't really have a
religion you just
got another iteration of the social
justice movement but i believe i believe
that weird stuff is absolutely central
to it
um
same thing with judaism uh
it's the things that make them different
from everything else that are the things
that you'd want to hold on to not the
stuff you'd give up yeah and and import
this like crappy d'angelo ism why would
you
why would you go from angels to d'angelo
that's a good question i should have uh
i consider dennis prager my rabbi i'll
have him i'll have him ask that next
time at the high holidays uh well from
there actually that's a good segue to
gratitude which is next in the book
man we could all use a little bit more
of that in the west huh yeah i think
some people are kind of waking up to it
now do you sense that there is a feeling
of oh man we might be really giving this
thing away
maybe things like ukraine remind us of
that you know you've got
people in 2022's homes are being shelled
by tanks and invading neighboring
country and
you know it could be us you know
maybe it helps a little bit to put in
proportion
the luck we have in
basically stable and vaguely peaceful
societies
or broadly peaceful
substantially peaceful mainly peaceful
societies
you know the reason why i write about
gratitude is because apart from in fact
it's been something that's been much of
my mind in recent years it's as i say
it's the only counter you can have to
resentment and we lit we've lived in an
age of resentment and the war in the
west is significantly a war waged by
resentful people
people who
wallow in resentment who wallow in
blaming other people for anything in
their lives that does not go right
you always have someone to blame
nietzsche again writes about this the
problem with resentment the problem with
resentful people
is that there is actually only one true
answer you can have to them to stop
their resentment which is to say to them
you are right
there is something
which is wrecking your life and is
ruining you
the thing is you
you are the thing
now
the problem with that is that that is
the last message anyone wants to hear
and so there will always be
an inbuilt reason for resentful people
to stop ever looking inwards
is that the greatest trick of social
justice in a way that it took everything
off the self it took everything off the
individual and just put it on the
machine it's certainly one of them and
you know you have to talk to these
things in similar but similar depths and
by the way i think this is something
right has got very badly wrong in recent
years
uh the left talks in terms of resentment
and the right will talk about tax cuts
you know that's not actually talking on
the same level yeah they're talking at a
tectonic level and the right is talking
at a fiddling level important fiddling
no doubt but fiddling
the only counter to real resentment is
gratitude is is to turn your attitude
towards life around
and to be encouraged to do so now
this is perfectly possible but but and
one of the things is to realize what a
life of resentment actually looks like
dostoyevsky and the brothers karamazov
um
has a
fantastic passage where the devil
appears and
says to one of the brothers the one the
brother he says to on the brothers that
gratitude is something he can't do
and when i read that first i thought
that's amazing only dostoevsky would
throw away that insight that the devil
is not capable of gratitude but you know
the gratitude comes or should come from
okay these are things that uh i mean if
somebody says for instance well what
what have you produced in the west other
than uh other than
slavery and racism and inequality and
all of these things i say okay let me
just start with cities paris
rome
florence
barcelona madrid
lisbon
venice portland used to be nice i
wouldn't list portland
the point is
the city
the list could go on almost endlessly
the great university cities heidel
heidelberg
regensburg oxford cambridge
you think this is nothing
i'm just talking about cities here i've
not even got onto the rest of it i've
not got on to scientific achievements
i've not got on to all the cultural
achievements
but i could
now if you look at it in that light
you'll be reminded that yes it's
possible to do what the
deconstructionists
argue that we should all do which is to
tear everything apart break everything
down always deconstruct everything other
than their own careers
you can do that or you can stand back
and look at what you have
i mean you could you could you could
look at a
block of marble and talk about the labor
that it cost to get it out of the
of the of the
the ground you could talk about the cost
of labor and whether or not people were
properly
uh
paid for getting it out of the ground or
you could stand back and look at the
pieta
you know
these are two totally different
attitudes but they're both possible
you can stand in
in venice and say what a terrible
testimony to inequality
or you could marvel
yeah know and there's one that's better
than the other i think that's what
you're saying get what i'm leaving i
think i think i got it i think i got it
uh culture is what you end on and we've
sort of this whole conversation in some
ways is couched around culture but
everyone says we're in a culture war
right now or the culture wars are raging
uh yes the the cultural one is the most
painful one in a way because this is
where the
d'angelo is and kendeism
this is where it is it is really it is
ugliest
it's when this horrible retributive game
looking at everything through the eyes
of slavery and colonialism
gets put onto this horrible beam gets
put onto the most delicate fragile and
precious things
i give examples of artwork that
has actually been
closed up now
including one of my favorite painters
uh
his work's been shut away in the tate
gallery in london because of a claim
that one of the one of the figures in it
is racist
and the man who painted this rex
whistler um
died on his first day in action in 1944
in normandy
uh he's posthumously been defamed
by the tate gallery as a racist he
wasn't a racist
and he lost his life fighting nazism and
they've defamed him posthumously they've
done the same thing with artist after
artist they're doing the same thing with
classical music at the moment
they can't find enough
black baroque composers
so what
yeah so what
uh and but there are baroque ensembles
across america that are now tearing
themselves apart over this orchestra is
doing the same thing
they notice that i mean that the canon
of western music and western literature
is horribly dominated by by what they
call dead white males by the way one of
the things i love in that is they they
don't only attack people for being white
and being males but for being dead
it's like what kind of a loser would die
the least they could do is stick around
so we can attack them to their faces you
know what kind of losers are these
people like bar
um
so these dead white males are now sailed
for absolutely everything and
um and as a result they've
these
anti-western activists have reduced the
arts to the same again banal retributive
aggressive resentful game as everything
else they've even done it on gardening
one of my favorite passages in this book
is is the passage racist gardening
um when i was doing the audio book i had
trouble with this bit because i was just
laughing so much i had to do so many
takes uh because it's just preposterous
there's even there's even a guy in
canada who made waves a couple years ago
who said that lawns are racist
the whole the whole idea of the the
perfect lawn is a racist construct
um
and the lawn mower is the slave master
or something like that i mean
his analogy
his analogy doesn't stand up to much
attention but um
they've done this to everything yeah and
um
[Music]
this causes in me a certain resentment
to itself because i think that
it's it's one of the
cruelest things you could do to the
gifts we've been given
uh
they've done it on shakespeare the globe
theater in london
now has a set of um seminars on
decolonizing shakespeare
uh they they found that his um he he
some of his characters uh aren't right
you can't believe it they weren't all
perfect shakespeare's characters one
shakespeare scholar in america said this
language of light and darkness i mean
this language is all over the place
saying well until quite recently people
used to think that shakespeare was quite
good with language better than your
average american academic for sure wait
till they find out about george lucas he
wrote a little something about the light
in the dark you know this it's it's all
it's it's all looked at in the same
light
as we are better than all of these
people you think you stand here to judge
shakespeare
you really think you have that right
uh
so so as i say that the culture bit is
the most painful in a way because
it's the same story as a war on white
people it's the same sort of the war on
our history the war on our religious
inheritance and our philosophical
inheritance and this is the war on our
cultural inheritance and it's all done
in the same way
with the same anger and
and resentment
and i try to explain
at the end how i think we get out of
that no
you don't have to give away the ending
but give me a nice ending for this and
then i and then i want to continue with
one other topic that we're gonna
we'll do like two or three minutes of it
for the public and then i want to shift
the rest of it to the locals community
regarding something else that you and i
have been talking about somewhat
publicly and privately um
but give me a classic
douglas murray adding to an interview as
only
douglas murray
god put some pressure on me no um
well here's what i think i think we've
been being polite
and i'm done with it
totally done with it
um
all of what i describe in this book is
only going on because
we happen to live in highly tolerant
societies
uh
so i give i give a set of
what it would look like if we stop being
tolerant
um
i mean here a couple of standoffs i
would do i feel this very strongly if
you don't respect my ancestors i've seen
no reason to respect yours
you know if you don't show any respect
for my history i don't see why i should
pretend
to respect yours
if you don't respect my culture
i don't need to respect yours
if you don't respect me i see no reason
to respect you
now
what does this look like this lack of
politeness
well it would look like telling some
truths that our ear has been too polite
not to
uh say
or
in recent years at any rate
in the end of his series on civilization
lord clarke memorably said that um that
uh
that that courtesy was one of the things
that defined the west
it's a very interesting thing to fall on
at the end of his thing but courtesy
courtesy is a hugely important thing in
western society but it's not endless so
here would be a non-courteous thing to
say
um
we've been told about other ways of
knowing
um
other ways of doing maths
non-race anti-racist science and all
this sort of thing
yet we do not go to any aboriginal
communities for vaccines
we go to no first peoples for cancer
treatment
we go to them for no mathematical
scientific or artistic discoveries
we do not go to them to
rediscover other languages and other
cultures
partly largely because such communities
seem to have had not much interest in
other cultures unlike the western mind
they seem not to have taken a great
interest
so
the
not courteous thing
would be us saying
we've been courteous for an awfully long
time and we're going to stop because it
seems not to be doing us much good
so
we will
pursue truth where ever we want to
pursue it for whatever means we have and
whatever disciplines we have and we will
stop pretending that alongside
all the great philosophy of the west
native american philosophy is equal
i mean i have a bit in the book where
lampoon these american authors who you
just know at the end of everything are
going to find a sort of
tribal leader who says something totally
banal
and claim that it's
amazingly profound but like i'm willing
i'm willing to pretend that for a bit
not really willing to pretend that we
can get rid of aristotle and plato and
voltaire and everyone else and keep only
boring tribal leader banality
so yeah the end process would be
um not playing nice anymore
and as it happens i don't think it would
be a very nice solution in itself
but i do fire it as a warning shot
like don't push us there
um
it is i mean it is a totally mad thing
to do within the west and i should
stress perhaps
this is about western anti-westernism
there are other types of anti-westernism
around the world but this is about
western anti-westernism and it is a very
strange thing to try to persuade
majority communities in societies to
believe that they are evil and
impossible
ever to atone for that evil
deangelo says
white people cannot get out of whiteness
and there is no good whiteness
no to hell with these people to hell
with them for pretending that a white
child born and brought up in the 21st
century in america has to be deemed as
having no good things to access through
their life
these people have to be cleared out of
the way
and
i'm trying to do my small amount to make
sure that happens
douglas murray you've still got it my
friend
still got it and uh i will have you on
for a tenth appearance if you will join
me again but so this is the end of the
proper interview but now i want to do
something a little bit different just
for a couple minutes and we'll leave
some of this on youtube publicly but
then i want to take the rest to locals
because i think it's interesting um we
did a panel at nat khan
uh where they were trying to piece
together it was me you yoram hazoni and
sora bamari and we were trying to piece
together what a new right could look
like
and sort of where the minorities fit
within that if a society is to have any
sort of traditional conservative values
and it was a pretty damn good
conversation if i do say so myself and
there were a couple hundred people there
for it um you know that david and i made
this announcement uh in the last couple
weeks about having kids and we're
obviously overjoyed and it's great and
99 of what i got especially from my
friends on the conservative side of the
aisle was amazing well nothing but love
and support a lot of it publicly plenty
of it privately but it was it was all
good
but there was
this mostly anonymous frog related but
not all some more religious people anger
towards this related to gay related to
ivf a whole bunch of other things and i
thought i don't want to pay too much
attention to what a small minority
you're saying but it's not nothing
and i often say to you at some point in
all of our interviews you so happen to
be gay zipity
here we are
but as as a conservative or a
i don't know all the words i don't want
to put anything in your mouth
what what do we do with this tension
what do you think we do with this
tension i discovered from the netcon
conference that the conservatives there
think i'm a liberal right well that's
why so that's why i mean it it's like
you're a liberal in the right sense of
liberalism right like no they think i'm
a liberal
right so yeah well they think even right
the right sense of liberalism liberals
are in the wrong sense of liberalism
so yes i'm with you on that right so
there's an alarming discovery
in some ways you were the most liberal
person on the panel in a certain
interesting position for me to be here
which is odd right so you're thought of
as a british conservative but from an
american context you were thought of as
a liberal in but but we had this debate
how can conservatism
come to grips grasping some of the
things that you write about religion
and
family
and that there's a
an inheritance over generations and all
of all of the stuff all of the stuff
and i don't want to you know it's funny
i haven't talked about it publicly that
much because i don't want to give too
much credence to it because it was it
was a very small minority of angry
people it wasn't
and and by the way not just angry people
because some of the things i think are
legitimate concerns you know if two gay
men have kids well where's the where's
the role of the mother right you know
things like there are things i've
written about that yeah there are things
to talk about so what what do you think
we do with all of this
um
well one realization i have had since
being in america is that i mean there
are uglier things in the woodshed than i
knew before on the right
i think that is true
uh
so i'm trying to nip this one in the bud
how about that yeah i
i i think there are uglier things on the
right
i think there are ugly things on the
right like there are on the left
everywhere um
i think maybe part of the right got a
bit complacent in recent years about
this you know we were so used to leftist
overreach you know jordan and i
talked quite a lot including publicly
about you know where the left goes wrong
and we did so partly in the
assumption that well everyone knows
where the right goes wrong but i think
that the right in america in particular
might be re-learning that lesson at the
moment
um maybe it's a never-ending lesson
um
i mean
there are people
i've had a couple of
totally minor
confrontations myself since being here
with sort of ugly troll-like figures but
slightly closer to the mainstream on the
right than i'd be comfortable with them
being
who
play with anti-semitism for instance
um
play with
other bigotries
i think they're sort of edge lords of
the right who
are basically doing the same
reprehensible game that parts of the
left do
they're
compares on the on the left you know
play with che guevara and
these guys play with pinochet you know
um
so what if we remove the the troll part
of it or the edgelord part of it or just
like the internet part of it but let's
say what do you think about just the
people that maybe have a purely
religious
perspective well the strange thing in
this country again it's something i've
discovered since you know
living here is
that that i mean you have something in
america which really doesn't exist in
britain which is i mean you have
i mean so-called integralists for
instance
i honestly i didn't take these people
seriously
i honestly thought they must be kidding
um but you you want to introduce for
instance catholic social doctrine as a
foundation for ethics in america that
was part of the conversation but i mean
like
catholics aren't even nearly a majority
in america right there's no way that a
minority
can assert
its
moral principles over a majority in a
secular republic
i mean no way you have to kill an awful
lot of people and in any case the
history of europe and the 16th century
ought to be some in 70th century ought
to be some
um
small
reminder of why
i mean i mean literally this is why i
couldn't believe that the integralists
were serious but i thought you don't
know how europe went down
on this very issue and how long it took
significant thinkers and brilliant
figures
to untangle this
why would you be trying to re-tangle
that again
[Music]
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell